welcome everybody thank you for for
coming this morning I'll be delivering a
talk to you about understanding the tech
community through notebooks obviously it
has to be through notebooks right this
is my data it couldn't be otherwise but
what I'm what I'm really about to tell
you about is it's basically my let's say
backgrounds projects you have a lot of
work you lot of things to do and there's
always this one thing you can kind of
get back to every every other week or so
for maybe a couple of hours and then at
some point these things kind of get out
of hand and that's exactly what happened
here and by now it's actually resulted
in a quite a nice little product that
I'll show you how we created that so
this is basically a notebook at the base
exploration of meetup com so who here
knows about meet up okay so maybe the
other way around who has never been to a
medium before all right let me explain
you a little bit about that before that
about this talk so this is basically a
list of tools that might be useful for
you a number of packages number
frameworks the number of ways of doing
things and this is also a exploratory
analysis of local tech communities
through meetup com but me I'm the CTO
forgot it's driven I think we're
actually kind of responsible for having
this event in Amsterdam in the first
place at some point somebody went to
London and came back and the next
morning told me hi freezer we're doing
PI data in Amsterdam ok so here we are
yeah that's my github profile picture
freezers also a very popular brand of I
think dairy products for infants or
something i'm on twitter upset k that
should be easy to remember i'm on github
as well and too much stuff there and
also forgot it's driven apart from the
CTO role i'm basically the chief meetup
organizer so here in Amsterdam I
organized the Hadoop you
group I organized a or co-organized meet
up on apply machine learning together
with somebody who is in the academic
world and also I'm partly responsible
for the Amsterdam apache spark meda so I
have a keen interest in meetups as do
many people so what is the meetup
basically according to the good people
of meetup themselves it is the world's
largest network of local groups and
making it easy to organize local events
where people get together and the
mission there is to basically to
revitalize the local community and help
people around the world self-organized
so that means that people you know
people get together and through through
an online meeting platform where they
make arrangements from meeting in the
offline real world and do things like
you know build houses or clean up the
neighborhood or go knitting in the park
and lots of yoga I suppose as well so
that's that's really what meetup is
about getting together in the real world
so if you look at meet up in general
it's it's an event-based social network
it focuses on events which are organized
by by groups so every meetup event
belongs to a meetup group and those
groups of members and the groups are
discussing particular topics that they
inherently care about like yoga or
self-help or I don't know apache spark
right so that's the idea but there's a
couple of things that we kind of also
used me that will come for and I think
primarily my prior about this audience
would be the you are pretty much
familiar with the tech made of
specialization in there so that's that's
kind of single evening many conferences
and you get usually free access and also
look pizza and beer for free have kind
of become a commodity in tech centers
because you can just go anywhere every
evening of the week so for us meetups
actually look a lot like this right
after work we go in dark rooms and we
have lots of pizza and perhaps a couple
of beers and we talk about work again
which is interesting enough and the
funny thing is actually that's what we
use me up for the most because if you
look at the number of groups there are
for each particular category the meetup
has then you see these two spikes in
that distribution so the one on the left
the right one is the category of
business meetups and the really big one
on the right there is the category of
tech or technology meetups so that means
if you look if you run into somebody who
knows about meetups then knowing nothing
else the likelihood of them being in
tech meetups is by far the greatest
there's 36 I think or so categories but
in the end in reality the majority of
meetup activity is just tech I think
that's good for us if nothing else
probably keeps the platform running as
well and it also inspires a lot of good
intentions with people so one of the
things that happens a lot is people get
carried away in their enthusiast image
they say you know what we'll start a
meetup group and then kind of slack off
and never really organize any events in
there but by the way this is just for
Amsterdam and the same here this is just
but the the Amsterdam made of community
did this particular behavior of starting
a group and then never organizing the
event is actually twelve percent of all
tech meetups so you know about one in 10
of us has just the good intentions and
and that's it now obviously meet up as a
platform is growing pretty rapidly right
so if you look at the number of meetups
over time that exists right here
announced them and this is just tech
meetups then you can imagine well twelve
percent of the meetups never really
organized anything but that could be
because they're just brand new right
most of the meetups will be a recent
because the platform is growing so
rapidly
but then if you look into it a little
bit and this is a bit of a weird plot
because the bidding is in uniform but
this is basically the histogram of the
age in days of made-up groups that never
organized anything so you can see right
here there's about 12 meetups they were
created in in the say the last week at
the time of collecting these data that
never did anything and I think they're
excused right you're still getting your
group together you're working on things
but then there's 35 meetups that were
created between a week and a month ago
that never did anything as well and then
there's this entire group here which is
a year and another year so those are
groups that are well over a year old and
never really did anything but it turns
out there's other uses as well so many
many people in let's say the evangelism
business have learned that meetup has a
quite nicely working recommender system
that will send you emails off about
anything you put in there as long as you
check the right topics that are
supposedly interesting to your meetup
and this is two and a half percent of
all tech meetups being just an
announcement for something else and not
actually being an event right there on
meetup so maybe they should work on that
a little bit so that's nice a couple of
things we learned about meet up so a
question now is how do we know all of
this right well obviously I didn't go on
to meetup comb and click around through
the side copy pasting all of this stuff
into excel so meetup has an API that you
can quite liberally use to grab a
substantial amount of data from them
it's there on the on website it's very
well documented it gives you a complete
view everything that happens on the
platform as long as you remember
yourself and also it's reasonably be
generous when it comes to rate limiting
and it does a proper implementation of
rest
this is an example he quest here we're
basically getting everything in category
34 which is tech in country Netherlands
city Amsterdam we're looking for three
results a page and we only want to see
the names and the organizers name of
meetup groups so this HTTP comment is
coming from something called HTTP you
should really get that if you ever do
command line rest calls it's so much
easier than then crow so which get out
of it is obviously response headers that
will have some some rate limiting
information as well and then
subsequently you get a bunch of Jason
showing the metadata so that says there
i have three results but then also i
have 897 results in total which is if i
go to the next page next place the next
place and so on you get all that and
then finally 30 actual jason body of the
results as well so that's nice now let's
look at what we're up to basically what
i wanted to do is get a feeling for the
tech community at large and i figured it
probably is a good idea to start with
the more interesting technology centers
that are out there in terms of software
engineering so me being from amsterdam i
put that first I think that's the
natural tendency for people from
Amsterdam and then I figured Berlin
London New York Chicago and San
Francisco should be nice as well
actually I didn't do Chicago initially
but I did at some point I wanted more
English language content to to Train
particular models so we look for all of
the groups within a hundred-mile radius
of these cities and then meet up will
basically give a whole lot of stuff so I
scheduled a little scraper that I wrote
in Python to go through the API and get
all the information on the group's the
events the members the RSVPs for the
people that actually express that
they're coming to an event the longest
of the HD
up stakes about 19 hours to run which is
for San Francisco understandably and I
scheduled this with Jenkins anybody not
know what Jenkins is alright so Jenkins
is technically a built server however
and you can nicely abuse it as a
scheduler because it will run your jobs
on a schedule and then also capture the
outputs and it can send you emails if
things fail so this is my Jenkins
instance and you can see here there's a
lot of jobs starting with meetup
downloader so those will nicely on
particular days of the week do a full
run of this jobs that grabs all the data
for a particular City and obviously this
thing can fill for for many reasons
although read limiting hasn't been one
of them yet because it turns out the
meetup API is so slow that if you don't
hit it with any parallelism you never
hit the rate limiting this is probably
also y de San Francisco job take 19
hours because the data said that comes
out of it is on the order of four and a
half gigabytes so that shouldn't take 19
hours but hey other things happen you
get broken connections every now and
then you get a you get a server error
and these kind of things so what I did
in the end is create a job the basically
keeps track keeps a list of all of the
URLs that still needs to hit in a little
psycho light database and then it's just
resumable so you can it can break and
then we could just restart it and it'll
pick up where it left off and then also
the adjacent blobs that it gets out of
it will go into sequel light as well in
just a little local database probably I
could have done this with scrapie as
well but I had already started on doing
a little resting myself so finish that
so that basically gives me a sequel I'd
database with all the downloaded Jason
blobs for all of these meetup activity
in these big cities or these texts
cities which is nice because it's full
data set but obviously it isn't very
convenient for many purposes because
well I have Jason blobs in a database
without indexes or anything else
so when I when I was thinking about the
domain of the problem obviously it
initially it always makes sense to just
think okay I'll do this in my sequel or
post graphs or something like that
because I can query nicely with sequel
but if you if you really think about the
meetups it is inherently network
structure so instead of doing a
relational database I used a graph
database to store it its data which
actually gives you a lot of interesting
opportunities so the graph database that
I used is neo4j it's there's a community
of edition which is open source and
there's an enterprise edition which can
do additional things but in the end it
will store a graph and provide you with
a nice API and also query language for
it so neo4j stores what we call property
graph so that means on the vertices and
on the edges of the graph you can store
properties as well and then you can also
use those properties when querying which
is which is very nice there's excellent
pythons forth through a package called
PI 2 neo and there is a query language
which is called cipher which basically
is like using ASCII art to describe what
you want so you can do things like give
me me which is a member by the name like
that so that's basically in the next
look up and then well just return that
and that should give me something but
not me
you guys are awake thank you so this
gives me a lot of me's because I I
obviously ran these jobs for four
different cities so I'm in there a
couple of times so I can also do this
predicate where there should be this
additional Amsterdam label on me and
then it will give me just me right here
in Amsterdam this is the the graphical
view and you can also get the view in
terms of rows where you just say you
know for each node and edge the queue
retreat from the database it will give
you a list of all the properties that
are in there so this is nice and you can
do things like this for example where I
say okay I am me a member and then there
is a venue out there somewhere and
basically give me the shortest path
between me and a venue for which this
predicate applies the city is Dumbo's
which is somewhere in the south of the
netherlands and then when you run that
query it's going to take a while but in
the end it will it will basically come
up with this where me is right here so
that's that's me and then this is a
venue in doubles this is venue in
dimples and this is one and it gives me
the shortest paths to to each of them
which is kind of nice because you can do
do quick explorations that way this is
what we call my ego network so this is
basically give me anything connected to
me through a relation called RSVP to an
event which is organized by some group
so that's a query that spans multiple
vertices and edges and it will give
anything that matches that which is the
network of me and all of the meetup
events that I ever went to including the
groups that organize them so this is
nice and also nice is the fact that you
can also do these kinds of queries where
instead of returning vertices and edges
you can return individual fields like
names or properties of nodes and edges
and also aggregates like counts so that
basically means instead of getting a
graph back you get just tabular data
back
so it's it's a nice way of getting the
graph data in a tabular form back to you
and then of course there's Python
integration through something called PI
2 neo which allows you to create this
graph object that accesses the graph
database through rest and then you can
do something like what's the database
size and it'll get you a number back
right here so there's about 2.6 million
things in my database you can query oh
that looks horrible if you have the
notebook in the normal screen it will
actually nicely align and be a little
table so here we basically get the last
10 events that I went to and then PI
tinea will give you that back in some
kind of character representation if you
represent it but then the result set
actually has some some more interesting
properties so the result object is
iterable and then also its list like so
it's fully materialized see you can do
things like get me the last element and
then the records within a result set
also a dictionary like but there are
also objects as you see on top where I
just use the object notation be kicking
you can also get them through a
dictionary notation especially for areas
that have spaces in them I know where
things that wouldn't be normally
expressible in in the Python language
and then it's pretty trivial to
construct and as data frame out of this
so what i'm doing here is using the fact
that the result set is a durable and
just feed that to the data stream data
frame constructor there possibly
renaming the columns and then all of
sudden I'm in pandas world which is nice
for a couple of things and we'll look at
that later and then there's this ipython
cipher package which helps you with a
couple of nice things first of all you
can do in line cipher queries using a
magic and then assign that to some kind
of result and the nice thing about the
result object that you get from this
ipod and cipher package is that the
representation is low
sir this way but also that it has this
get data frame function that will ya
return your data frame so you're more
easily in into pandas then and then
there's cell level magic for just
putting a query there and viewing the
results in your notebook so now that we
have this set up there's a couple of
things that we can trivially do so for
example when I'm organizing a meet up
every now and then I'm sometimes need to
look for a venue and one of the easiest
things to do then especially if the
group is pretty substantial in size is
basically say okay give me all of the
venues and Amsterdam that ever hosted
anything before and sort them by some
kind of median event size and and tell
me which are which are the groups that
they've hosted so then what you get is
this this entire list of venues and I
can see the median event size that
happened there and the groups that were
ever hosted at that venue so this is
really convenient for me so I can just
send out a bunch of emails to two venues
that are probably in a market for
hosting one of the data meetups so
that's nice I'm really convenient so you
can do things like this where you
basically say okay I run a query that
will give me the size of each of the
meetup groups and then I put that in a
data frame and then subsequently I just
do a histogram like this and i will tell
me most of the meetup groups are pretty
small and then there's a couple of
larger ones and there is a lot of like
these power distributions in there which
are to be expected so one other thing
that I i think is interesting to look at
is the the overlap between different
meetup groups it basically tells you
something about how alike are these two
audiences whenever the overlap it's
really hard to not think about fen
diagrams and luckily there's a package
that creates Venn diagrams and matte lip
it's really nice they can do a Venn
diagram out of two or three sets and you
just feed it a number of sets
we defined this little function here
that does a cipher query gets the member
sets for a couple of meetup groups and
then feeds that to this Venn diagram
function and it can do this so we have
here the PI data elements and the UM
star dumb meetup group what's the
hyphens there and other things which may
or may not be a reference to well the
syntax language but it's quite obvious
that there's a bit of overlap the our
meetup group is larger because it's been
around longer and it was to be expected
that there was some overlap there and
you can do the same with a graph
database group in the Netherlands and
then you get this nice diagram of the
different number of co-occurrences in
those member sets and then we can do
something like this where you see that
there's you know the r and the the graph
database and the PI data groups have
half a bunch of overlap in the graph
database and this Coco hats which is a
mobile app development group also has
some overlap but PI data doesn't have
overlap with Coco hats so the sort of
might imply that there's like two
different communities out there that do
have some form of common interest but
not entirely or not enough to be a
community and then obviously there's
also completely disjoint things which is
kind of disturbing because you know out
of the the data community right here in
the Netherlands absolutely zero are part
of the a light group of tomorrow's IT
leaders so obviously i immediately try
to fix this by signing up for tomorrow's
IT leaders meetup group but it turns out
they have to let you in and
so um it's a work in progress i'll keep
you posted but this does quite clearly
implied combined with with these kind of
things that are quite likely communities
within these network within his networks
so that that leads us to to the next
topic where we start taking a bit of a
closer look at the network what i've
used for that is a package called i
graph i graph is available in python in
our it's a c library has bindings in in
both it's not entirely ready for python
3 yet but there are some trivial fixity
he can do and i got the PR accepted so
it's probably in an upcoming release it
will be fixed otherwise if you install
it right now it's or paper in python 3
the plotting is broken but then again
mostly you use python 27 anyway right i
graph a group stands library for you
know working with graphs it can do some
graph global things and also do
calculations on individual vertices like
as between us and centrality and these
kind of things and then also there's
algorithms for traversal but also
community detection which is the thing
that we're interested in here so this is
again my my ego network but then created
as a digraph objects and I'm plotted in
in a notebook so this is just this is my
proclip it actually generates an SVG we
can see your I'm there in the center all
the Sian verses are events that don't
have names on them and the green things
are groups so their meetup groups so so
this is basically my surrounding in
terms of the meetup graph and then when
I expand that by putting like two
members in there you can already see
that given to members there sometimes
some commonality but there's also
particular groups that are completely
disjoint given these two members
and then when you go on like that and
you add people then obviously you kind
of see these parts in the graph where
you have different densities so instead
of actually having a look at that which
is fairly hard to visualize no it
doesn't really tell you loan me a few
things we're just going to let an
algorithm decide these our communities
and these are in and then from that
point on will look into those
communities and see whether it makes
sense so what I did is basically take
all the meetup groups in Amsterdam and
relate them relate the members to those
groups through the events that those
members went to and then the the edge
weight of an edge between a group and a
member is determined by how active that
member is in that group with some decay
over time so if I am active in a group
more recently that means more than I
used to go there a year ago or something
there's a couple of biases in here
because you know sometimes groups just
sees activity in general so that nobody
is active anymore and there's a couple
of other effects that are pretty hard to
take into account but generally this
gives us interesting results already so
we run the community detection and I
graph so this is basically what we do
here we say give me everybody in let's
say the greater amsterdam area that and
then all the activity that was prior to
january first of this year this is also
to account for the fact that there's
quite some seasonality in the innovative
event data and then the data frame that
comes out of that is basically a group a
member and then a timestamp and recency
so we need to transform that into a
group a member and something that's at
that particular weight and then from
there on we need to construct a graph
out of basically this list of edges and
now an i graph that's pretty trivial
actually create a graph through
something they call it tuple list and
what I do here the graph relations is
just the data frame so that's the one
you see here that has these three
columns and I basically tell the values
of that data frame is a list of tuples
with weights and boom you have a graph
and then we can run community detection
on that so the community detection I
graph has a lot of different algorithms
most of them are not very scalable but
the the one that you would primarily use
on larger graph is an iterative method
of community detection which also will
actually return you a hierarchy of
communities if you like I think its
scope I'm actually not sure I hear a
community multi-level the implementation
as far as I'm aware is actually an
implementation of what is better known
as the Louvre an algorithm which is a
greedy methods for optimizing network
modularity so it returns you all of the
different levels and then the last level
of that is the most coarse-grained so
maybe the first level it will detect
like 300 communities and then maybe 100
and then the last level is what you
actually get and that's 46 so this is
nice because we just went back from from
like 700 or 800 I think I think 900
meetup groups by now to only 46
communities that that share some
commonality in interest huge it probably
because the network was constructed by
attaching people to groups based on
their activity within that group so some
communities are victims some are small
these are all the different communities
that are detected so 0 2 45 which is 46
and these are the sizes of that
community of each of the community so
you can see the largest one over there
slightly over 3,000 and the smallest one
is somewhere well quite close to 0 so
there's there's a couple of perhaps a
noisy kind of members in the network
that don't really add to to an empty
murmur to the global picture and
when you look at the size distribution
it looks a lot like this so most of the
communities are are somewhere between
zero and five hundred and then there's a
couple of larger ones so what we did
next is try and establish a rank so
basically we're going to say so what is
the more important community out of
these the way we did that is basically
take this community detection that we
ran an i graph and then put the results
back into the Neo database so then
subsequently becomes really easy to just
query things based on the community that
they were part of and then for each
community what you say okay so what a
top ten meetup groups that play a role
within this community and from those
will say okay what is the activity
amongst those meetup groups for that
community and that that that basically
gives us an activity rank and that will
say so in 2015 this was the most active
community within the Amsterdam texting
and we have that we have that rank and
you have those top end groups for each
of the communities I you can finally
start to look at something and a week
and it can also compare these different
cities so this is Amsterdam and we're
not doing the top 10 here but it's only
the top three so you can see the
community number on the left which is
signed by by the algorithm and then the
rank on the right the basically says so
this is the number one meetup group in
that community and so the community
numbers obviously don't mean anything
which is arbitrarily assigned but the
rank does mean anything and what you can
already see here is that there there is
you know on the surface of it some
commonality between the groups that go
in a community so you can see it in
Amsterdam this whole startup and
innovation thing is really big and then
secondly there's like the devil's crowd
and then on the third place alas there
is the big data and data science and
then you know moving on front end
general web development Internet of
Things and smart smart cities and these
kind things and then here is PHP and
over general development
so when we take after them and we
compare this to Berlin you can already
see that there's there's commonalities
but there's also some differences so for
example in Berlin the microservices is
actually a thing and then second second
community there is pretty much the big
data data science perhaps in that sense
they're ahead of us and then Willem
Berlin also not GS is actually thing but
that's also more elected general so for
development right general web
development no chess meteor which is I
think in PHP CMS or something no it's
not our makes sense ok so that that's
all JavaScript then and then there's a
geek girls and an open tech and that's
interesting because what we don't have
that in Amsterdam I'm not sure about the
the open tech but we don't have you know
meetups specifically targeted at getting
women to code that are also the most
active ones I mean they're there but
they don't surface into the top 10 but
if we go on to let's say no London but
San Francisco you see there the women
who code is a larger community that hack
actually has several meetup groups
focusing on just that and also over time
they've already went down in the top 10
a bit so that basically means that on
the technology side in Amsterdam we're
not doing too horribly although the big
data and data science is only in third
place so we need to work on that a
little bit but for the rest there's like
these these other kinds of movements
that for some reason we completely don't
take part at so shame on you Amsterdam
but perhaps it's just a matter of you
know getting the activity count up so
the service is interesting we basically
get an idea of the different sub
communities within the tech scene in
these different cities
and then what else can we do so we
haven't looked at the contents of these
events yet and the command and what
these groups are made up of but it turns
out on meetup all of the groups actually
a group creation specify a number of
topics that will that supposedly
interest the people who become a member
of that group and then from their own
obviously a group will at some point
start organizing events and those have
descriptions and there's a lot of
textual textual data that we could could
have a look at as well so what we we aim
to do then is basically try and come up
with an unsupervised and automated way
of building you know a global picture of
what what these communities and what
these meetups are about that let's sail
a man or IT managers as we call them can
use to figure out you know what's
happening in in this pool of people that
they're so desperately trying to hire
from but don't have a clue what these
people do on those you know thursday
evenings in in a room somewhere with
their pizzas and beers so in the end
that's that's what we're trying to
achieve here so these topics they're
there they're pretty static or if you
create a meetup group maybe some years
ago and back then I don't know MapReduce
was the greatest thing so so that became
a topic of your group but then over time
you know the world changed but the topic
state is saying but the event
descriptions are a lot more dynamic so
they'll pick up on all these new topics
for related phrases so the big idea here
is to yet basically used is these topics
to determine what a group is about but
then link those topics two words and
phrases that are in the event
descriptions which are more dynamic and
will reflect more or less him modern or
more recent trends in the community and
then we try and link all that together
to create one big network visualization
because that will also be able to show
you four different communities whether
let's say the topics in beat
that linked them together but not
strongly enough to make them a joint
community I think perhaps before we get
to the implementation just to kick you
an idea what that looks like so we
figured hey we can use all this data to
create a technology raider one of the
marketing people is going to come up
with a better name but this is just my
prototype look has a nice picture of
Amsterdam there's communities in here
you can see the activity charts for each
of the communities and then for each of
the communities you can see which are
they're important groups who are the
important people and then what is the
activity within there and then finally
this is like the big idea of these
communities link to their topics and
then linked to whatever they they care
about that's not readable but you can
see that for here there PHP web
development and then in that facility
there's PHP stuff but if you look at
let's say big data that assigns over
here and functional programming and
scalable systems over here and the thing
that they have in between there is like
no sequel and Hadoop and Cassandra which
is kind of interesting I don't know how
flask came up there we're working on
that so so what we do is we take all of
the event descriptions that are in
English because English is easy and
we're lazy so we have to start somewhere
there's a passing package called lanky
text which does that really nicely
especially on longer texts like like
event descriptions it's extremely slow
so it's written in pure python and and
it works on on character trigram
distributions so it has to do all of the
the classifications based on that so so
we trivially paralyzed that on a local
machine using apache spark and then we
strip HTML using beautiful soup I think
most of you will have heard of that and
then we run Jensen's excellent
implementation of work to vac on that
which I think right now is kind of the
state of the art in easily accessible
text representation local parallelism
would spark a little bit of a sidestep
you can you can run apache spark on your
local machine but just firing pi spark
and then where it says local and then
between the brackets as eight that means
it will take eight cores and that's it
so that will give you a local runner of
spark using eight cores and then what we
do in spark is basically say okay I'm
going to create a paralyzed data set out
of all of the group IDs that I have in
the database so that's the local
operation and I and then I push that
into parallel data structure and then
from there on and you're going to say
okay so now i can do a let's say absurdo
distributed operation so it's going to
be distributed across those eight cores
where I say okay so each of these spark
process is going to take a part of the
data and actually fetch those groups
from the database so this will create
parallelism against the database which
of course has to be able to handle but
then if in the end the goal is to
parallel lies this this one very slow
pure python package this works very
nicely it was realized that that
especially from items Park has quite a
lot of overhead so for for general at
i/o bound kind of things it's probably
better to just stick with local but in
these particular situations this works
quite nicely and then on the resulting
event descriptions we actually don't do
a lot of pre-processing at this point so
some still working a bit on the on the
text stuff doing a bit of pre-processing
doing trying to to actually clean up a
couple of the nasty things like hash
tags and URLs and this kind of thing but
right now we actually don't do any of
that and already it can do things like
this saying hey what's similar to
machine learning I will come up with
computer vision and statistical modeling
and deep learning and data modeling but
also for iOS it will know Android and
Windows Phone
iphone and mobile so that that's pretty
nice and it's a pretty useful model for
for the thing that we want to create and
then in the visualization we basically
connect communities to the topics that
are prevalent in the groups of that
community and then we rerun tf-idf over
that because a lot of these groups have
an interest in computer programming but
yeah and then from those topics well
that actually doesn't fit let me see you
again now it does so from those topics
we recursively look at the similar terms
up to a particular threshold so
determination criteria is basically the
similarity should be above some number
and then for each iteration in the
recursion we DK that with a little bit
and at some point it just stops and then
yeah the final result is this which I've
just shown you this network of
communities and topics and related terms
initially it would perform pretty poorly
but we fix that by grabbing more data
from the API hence Chicago was in there
and I think that's it perhaps we have
some question time if there are any
yes I couldn't hang stunt the first
thing sorry the Jensen package also has
a thing called doc to vac instead of
word to back did you get around to play
with it now I haven't used it in this
context so one of the things I am so the
question is did you look at doc to vex
so document the factory instead of work
defect so the one thing that I am
looking at right now is some other work
that's recently been published and also
implemented in a couple of places where
instead of taking individual works you
enrich the words with part-of-speech
tagging where you say you make the
distinction basically between a word in
its different meanings in a noun and a
verb and that that looks quite promising
also in in relating things so for
example there's little words in there
like agile which is just an objective
but there is an entire community of
people who turned it into a noun but
they capitalized it and then play games
with sticky papers but so these
distinctions are pretty important there
anything else yes
I know I'm a CTO said in the duty I I
don't sleep a lot so say the question is
did where do you find the time to do
these things don't you have a job yes I
do have a job but yeah it's is like I
said it's a background project other
questions all right I think we'll leave
some time for next weekend and thank you
yeah